il ya un truc je voulais revenir sur un
sujet qui a fait énormément réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est tjrs en top
twenty hier toute la soirée
tout le monde en parle et c'est les
régulations dacquois même à cobain un
blogueur qui dit que vous n'étiez
apparemment pas célibataire pendant le
tournage de l'émission sur son compte un
stade
le blogueur explique que la petite amie
de mathieu lorée même accompagner dans
les démarches de l'émission pour se
servir de sa notoriété et faire de la
télé réalité plus tard guillaume genton
vous avez 8 alors j'ai recueilli le
témoignage de deux femmes qui affirment
avoir été en couple avec vous avant et
pendant le tournage regarder on alors
photo assez de femmes
on a de jessica 31 ans de lyon qui dit
avoir été en couple avec aurélien donc
avant le tournage pendant trois-quatre
mois séparation juste avant le tournage
il a le droit motif de la rupture il
rêvait de faire la télé réalité j'ai
envie de répondre et notamment la villa
des coeurs brisés je termine juste
deuxième femme cindy 35 ans de cannes
j'ai été en couple avec mathieu pendant
plus d'un an et pendant le tournage
séparation après le tournage le 14 mars
2021 cause de la rupture la notoriété
lui monter à la tête qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez moi avait alors déjà je
trouve ça triste je vais voilà c'est je
la connais oui je la connais cette femme
moi j'ai des enfants elle a des enfants
bien sûr je pense qu'à un moment donné
en fait il ya d'autres moyens de se
faire de l'argent ou de faire du buzz en
manipulant systématiquement quelqu'un
parce qu'elle savait que j'allais faire
cette expérience en fait j'ai rencontré
au tout début de l'expérience et je lui
ai dit dès l'instant où j'ai su que je
faisais cette expérience je lui ai dit
je lui ai dit écoute on peut pas
continuer donc j'ai rencontré au début
je dis on peut pas continuer parce que
je suis capable de jongler sur deux
tableaux et m'investissant à fond dans
cette expérience
mais en fait je lui ai dit on a le choix
mais moi je ne conçois pas de vivre avec
toi je l'accepté entièrement qu'elle m'a
dit j'ai l'acceptant qui revient avec
elle pendant le début de l'émission au
nom au casting 16 ans et voilà on s'est
rencontré en janvier au tout début des
castings à marseille d'accord donc donc
après oui on a flirté pas de problème
j'apporte sauf qu'elle est non mais
lesquels elle était au courant elle est
tout content tout ça mais moi si vous
voulez elle m'a toujours dit il n'y a
pas de problème on se verra pour les
beaux moments on se verra de temps en
temps mais en aucun cas je te causerait
des problèmes par rapport à ça je vais
te laisser hommes mariés par la suite tu
feras tout ce que tu as tu auras envie
de faire avec cette femme
et puis voilà mais je pense que c'est
également couple qui maquille my mais
peut-être qu'elle a eu vraiment des
grosses harriman
pour agir comme ça je le vois comme ça
et après au final du coup est bien là
elle elle veut me faire payer ça avec
cette vengeance aujourd'hui alors la
question
je les adore mois ses jumeaux moi je
vous le dit voilà je les adore ces
gentilles et ils sont souriants ils ont
voulu craquer ils ont participé à marier
au premier regard y en a un qui a trouvé
l'amour
on sait pas si c'est sûr ou pas parce
qu'on le saura dans deux semaines mais
ses marques et voilà qu'elle s'est
mariée et a eu à l'autre elle est partie
at elle prévenu qu'elle allait partir et
puis maintenant il est très heureux il a
des enfants il veut rester célibataire
il ya eu cette affaire qui a été révélée
par un bloggeur aquabike qui dit que
vous étiez avec quelqu'un avant de faire
cette émission et série dans cette
émission il faut être absolument
célibataire bah oui si on va pouvoir y
est bien ce qui les lie battait abbaoui
et comme cette base on allait jouer au
tennis et qu'on avait des jets de
raquette
l'exemple n'est pas bon pourtant fait en
gaieté oui donc on a eu l'arrêt de fin -
et donc de mathieu voilà qui était avec
cette jeune fille c'est vrai que vous
avez été vous avez passé le casting nous
étions en ken mais ça c'est voilà ça
c'est ça c'est bah elle savait en tout
chaque jeu faisant l'expérience accord
est à 200% donc me disait l'accepter
quand on se voyait de temps en temps
mais en fait
enfin pour moi dans ma tête c'était
clair ses filets j'allais me marier avec
ma future et qui avec d'éventuelles
exactions
voilà oui oui bah non mais moi je trouve
pas ça très correct je suis désolé parce
qu'en fait on a plus l'impression que
elle elle était très amoureuse de vous
et que finalement elle n'avait pas choix
et que par amour vous allez c'est parti
ce désir d'exil dans le sens où on peut
pas contrôler ses sentiments mais si
j'étais d'accord avec itella est
définitivement aînés vous dites eu la
joie hier laurent je suis d'accord avec
vous et je n'ai pas quitté parce qu'à un
moment là à ce moment là dans ma vie
j'étais moi aussi un petit peu fragile
et fragile exactement donc j'avais
j'avais si vous voulez j'allais chercher
un petit peu aussi ce bonheur qu'on
pouvait avoir de temps en temps aussi
avec cette personne oui à travers ça
mais mais sans pour autant sans pour
autant avoir la sincérité de cette
expérience à 200% l'investir et où
l'application que ça pouvait comprendre
ce qui vit n'est pas convaincu
apparemment la cc66 socialiste des
sentiments j'ai trouv attendrissant
c'est la manche il a mené les frais mais
surtout trouver la dent dure j'ai
toujours voulu retrouver attendrissant
appétissant
c'est la première fois pour être honnête
mais je regardais cette émission c'est
magnifique j'ai fait mais en fait j'ai
même elle la file à marignane elle est
quand même subi bien sûr mariana la
duchesse est très très beau comme un
dieu bénisse 1 alors moi vous alors
c'est quoi cette histoire est ce qu'on
peut remettre le tableau guillaume
genton il s'est échoué le faire avant le
tournage
oui mais m'a dit vous étiez en coupe
quand vous avez commencé les démarches à
jeudi
sarah fait y'a même pas d'histoires de
couples j'étais en vacances sur lyon je
suis allé sur un site de rencontres j'ai
rencontré cette fille sur un site de
rencontres je lui ai dit que j'allais
participer à un casting donc c'était six
mois avant le mariage était même pas sûr
de faire l'émission j'allais faire un
casting pour une émission de rencontres
je veux juste m'amuser
elle m'a dit ok d'accord elle m'a dit
viens chez moi elle m'a dit viens chez
moi mais comme elle a monté son plan
elle faisait des photos elles me
disaient non mais je te kiffe trop bien
on fait des photos tous les deux alors
qu'en fait j'ai des textos ou elle me
dit non les photos c'est que pour moi
l'un est en fait bien voilà ce qu'elle a
fait avec les photos de fêtes elle
manipule si je peux juste dire et je
n'ai vu que je l' ai vu qu en février et
je les ai vu qu en mars et en mars on
échange d'anneaux de raffinement on
savait même pas si elle avoir le marié
au premier regard cas laisse faire et
j'étais même pas encore au courant si
j'avais une compatibilité
donc en fait à ma juste manipuler tout
simplement angulaire viager avec joue je
voulais dire ouais c'est en fait c'est
je trouve ça même même complètement
ahurissant dans le sens où même moi mon
frère on se dit quasiment tout vol
n'était même pas au courant s'exerçait
savoir si ma mère maintenant qu'ils ont
su satisfaire mon team et qui s est
vengé je connaissais pas cette femme
donc mon frère m'a expliqué après
vaguement dans les grandes lignes j'ai
dit c'est dommage pour toi c'est triste
non plus a même paru par rapport aux
photos cc que des photos où on est
allongé au torse nu quand c'est vrai on
fait plein d'autres photos où je sais
pas en val d'or
bien sûr non mais si ce n'est avec
allongée torse nu les mots c'est pareil
les mots qu'on emploie j'ai jamais dis
ma chérie mon bébé mon amour comme je
suis quelqu'un quand je suis amoureux
d'une fille je n'ai pas de mal à dire je
t'aime ou à dire des mots comme ça la
saison difficile je suis copain qui m'a
quand même dit mon chéri pendant la pub
j'ai de l'amitié